the bears and the rams and again last
year it was going to be cowboys rams it
was cowboys rams because no one was
there to see it you had to watch it you
know
from home um
the bears they got justin fields all of
a sudden the bears are you know
maybe they are may they aren't who we
thought they were we could say about the
bears going into 2021 now that they have
justin fields so uh you know good
defense
rams have a good defense matthew
stafford who knows the bears well
there's a lot of tentacles there and a
lot of new players and
you know it's going to play out in that
awesome new stadium
on sunday night football up and uh
that'll be that would be a great way to
cap the day
it will i mean for two big markets
the bears are a good football team it
definitely will be better if we have
justin fields starting at quarterback
there's no doubt about that
so that'll be something to see and again
you know you trade up from number 20 to
pick 11
and as long as the guy shows that
he's capable of running the offense and
not being a total disaster like you play
him
get the season started go like
stardom go ahead uh that's the way i
feel about it with a guy like justin
fields they can figure out ways to help
him out
keep the game simple and especially
because of the way he runs the football
and everything like that
so that's of course like something i
want to see i want to see justin fields
but i'm the most excited to see
and and matt stafford that's the one i
i'm definitely most excited to do
you know mcvay has a really good history
in opening weeks
and one it's because of something you
said already mike
like he's a guy that i i would think is
from the gruden school of thought
and that's what we did with gruden mike
we'd go all in on that week one match
up all in like my rookie year they just
won the super bowl right
they found out they were gonna open the
year up against the eagles
on monday night right and they opened
you know rocky was there to open the new
stadium and all that
i mean i'm saying early may all we did
was start working on eagles and they
remember the great defensive coordinator
jim johnson right for the eagles back in
the day he was famous for all his
blitzes you remember him right
yes he had all these crazy blitzes and
i mean gruden and our coaching staff
were obsessed with making sure we could
pick them up and not waste our back
and get them all there and everything
like that and mcveigh that's where i i
think he's going to have some cool plan
of attack with stafford and they'll be
ready to go and i just can't wait to see
that
yeah i i i agree with you completely and
uh you know both of these teams would
benefit from getting off to a good start
the rams are in a difficult division
they can't afford to fall to 0-1
with the 49ers with the cardinals with
the seahawks now
you know all those all those teams have
challenging games when you look at it
the 49ers
as we discussed earlier they go to
detroit the seahawks go to indianapolis
and the cardinals go to tennessee
those are not going to be easy games for
any of those teams so
maybe maybe we'll have three of the
teams oh and one
in the nfc west to start the season and
remember don't freak don't freak out
when your team goes 0-1 there's still
there's still 16 games to go that's the
beauty of it this year
completely forget about week one there's
still 16 games left
yeah i i mean you're right little little
like little
extra wiggle room there and everything
like that and you know you brought up
like the matchups of the nfc west too
hey i'll tell you what that they are
scary you know i
i would always be scared you know if
you're the 49ers and you're playing the
lions where yes at
you know base level at i you know just
at first look you go yeah the 49ers are
better
but where that stinks for those matchups
for the 49ers
or even maybe like the seahawks got to
play the colts there's a
there's moving parts like the 49ers
gonna be like we don't we don't really
know what to expect on them on offensive
side of the ball
we don't really know how they're going
to attack there's no history with this
staff
we're not really sure so that's going to
like swing the pendulum to even out
you know the game itself and the same
thing even with the colts like yes the
the seahawks are going to have a good
idea of what the colts like to do and
everything
but i'm sure with frank reich and now
having carson wentz
who's you know physically more gifted
than philip rivers was
you know at in year 17 or 18 of his
career last year
they're gonna have new things that they
bring to the offense and you can't
really prepare for
so that's that's always a tough thing
and we just talked about the rams they
could be dealing with justin fields and
a running
quarterback and all those type of things
so that gives some of the lesser teams
an
advantage here in week one because of
that unknown as far as the schematics
are concerned
um you know it makes me wonder you
mentioned justin fields
does the fact that they open with the
rams yeah i know that
change in any way because four years ago
the bears kept mike glennon on the field
now this was pre-matt nagy
but mike lennon was on the field for the
first month and then they went to
mitchell trubisky right
when you know that you're facing the
rams when you know that you
are in a big spot nationally
televised prime time game to start the
season
does that cause you to say hey yes we
made the bold move
to go get this guy we're getting him
ready we're getting him ready sorry andy
sorry we you qb won in march
not qb1 in september i think it's
i think that in that situation
mike you my history with coaches and
being you you would err on going
let's start the veteran on the road we
think that'll be uh
we'll we'll see with the fans but a
really talented defense in the rams the
number one defense in football
and like i just talked about with like
those nfc west teams playing teams that
they don't know about
they got a new d coordinator there so it
is going to be a different defensive
look
and the one thing we saw from raheem
morris last year is that as the
interim head coach of the falcons and
all that too now with the rams as the d
coordinator man they were exotic and
that's where
you know it could go two ways they could
go matt nagy going
damn it just they do too much and
they're too talented on defense i don't
want to do
i don't want to throw our rookie out
there and have them deal with this or
the other side of that story could be
mike hey
wait we put justin fields in and now we
have the threat
of this running quarterback and playing
11 on 11 football and doing all that
it might simplify the rams and make them
play a really base defense because
they're going to be worried about making
all the right run fits with now that
they're compromised to stop the run game
with a justin fields type at quarterback
but i would say more
what would you do i think more would air
on starting the veteran
but i don't know my points do they ring
true to you as far as the justin fields
aspect
i'm putting fields you are on the field
yeah i'm
look i don't trade from 20 to 11 to give
up next year's first round pick to put
this guy on ice
for andy dalton andy dalton was
the insurance policy that allowed you to
move around the draft board and get
the guy you wanted because you didn't
enter round one of the draft desperately
yes or a quarterback that's right
it it wasn't red circle underlined
highlighted bears are getting a
quarterback today and
and i think having andy dalton may have
may have allowed them to get
you know that trade done for a little
bit less than what it would have taken
because hey fine giant screw you
yeah you just lost we're okay right you
want to drop out and get cadary's tony
later
we're fine here we're fine at 20 because
we got andy dalton
you could sell that with no face you
could um semi i
i don't know but uh but yeah now that
you've done this
it's justin fields you got to go justin
fields yeah i agreed
agreed and you know you brought up a
point right after the draft too
where i do think you know like
you you painted the picture of what the
bears did
to where if we get out of training camp
and it's just like
you know no doubt it's andy dalton a
starter bam he's just
like yeah you're going to hear bears
fans going like what our guy
can beat out andy dalton and all that i
i do think that's going to be a topic of
conversation and going to put a little
more pressure
on the situation altogether so uh i'm
with you
i i err on playing them as well and they
can find ways to manage the game and do
some things to help him out
and like i said his running aspect i
think could really simplify the rams in
a lot of ways and allow the bears to
play a game maybe that they want
where they control the clock and now
play through their defense a little bit
and play that game because i don't think
they're going to want to get in the
shootout with the rams
that type of thing i don't expect the
the bears to be able to win that type of
football game
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports